IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME,
FANTASTIC SLAMS.
ALL RIGHT, COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA
SHOW YOU A PICTURE OF A TRULY
UNFORTUNATE HAIRCUT AND FOR 250
POINTS I WANT YOU TO TELL ME THE
NAME OF THE STYLE, ALL RIGHT?
THIS UNFORTUNATE YOUNG, UM, UH,
LAD OR... LAD OR LASS.
(BELL DINGS)
WHAT IS THAT, UH, CALLED,
JORDAN?
>> UH, THAT IS THE UNWANTED
MASSAGE-GIVER.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
RANDALL.
>> UH, THE DRAPES DO MATCH THE
CARPET.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
IT'S ALL RIGHT THERE.
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR, MY PUBIC
HAIR IS VERY WEIRD.
>> YEAH, THAT'S...
>> THAT IS WHAT I WAS INFERRING.
>> YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: IT'S JUST THE SAME
EXACT CONFIGURATION.
NEXT ONE-- HOW ABOUT THIS...
THIS.
(BELL DINGS)
YES, SAM.
>> THAT'S A FAT WOLVERINE.
>> HARDWICK: I DON'T KNOW... I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE TO...
POINTS.
UH, RANDALL.
>> THE PRODIGY SINGER TODAY.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
I'M A FIRESTARTER.
>> SMACK MY BITCH TITS.
>> HARDWICK: UH, NEXT ONE-- THIS
KIM SCALP.
(BELL DINGS)
OH, THAT'S THE BACK OF SOMEONE'S
HEAD.
UH, RANDALL.
>> THE FIRST TO DIE IN THE
APOCALYPSE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
THAT POOR GUY'S GOT TO KEEP
SWATTING RAPPER DICKS AWAY FROM
THE BACK OF HIS HEAD.
>> STOP, STOP.
>> HARDWICK: STOP IT!
IT'S JUST A HAIRCUT.
>> THAT BETTER NOT BE A DICK ON
MY HEAD.
THAT'S A DICK ON MY HEAD, I'M
GONNA BE VERY ANGRY.
>> HARDWICK: LAST ONE-- HOW
ABOUT THIS EYEGLASS MODEL?
HOW ABOUT THIS EYEGLASS MODEL?
(BELL DINGS)
JORDAN.
>> THE DR. SUESS RECEPTIONIST.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
POINTS.
RANDALL.
>> UH, THE PICK A TUFT AND FUCK
IT.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
POINTS.
UH, SAM.
>> UH, THE I CLEARLY WRITE
LETTERS TO SERIAL KILLERS.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
PERFECT.